[موسيقى]
هذه هي نشره المساء من العربيه لكم كل
التحيه انا ريما مكتبي نبدا بابرز
العناوين
حرب طويله جدا
ويشرف على انطلاقه فرقاطه بصواريخ عابره
هذا شوفير
وفي المانيا ايرانيون يخشون على حياتهم من
مخابرات بلادهم ويطالبون بحذر حذر الحرس
الثوري
بعيدا يتهم الجمهوريين بالفوضى وترامب
يدعو الى عدم تحويل النص لهزيمه محرجه
لتعويض يا خسائر بعد تعليق عده شركات
اعلاناتها على المنصه تويتر يسمح
للسياسيين باستخدام المنصه للترويج
[موسيقى]
وفي مستاهله هذه النشره نذهب مباشره الى
واشنطن والجوله الرابعه لانتخاب رئيس
المجلس النواب الامريكي بعد فشل ثلاث
جولات بسبب خلافات الجمهوريين وقبل قليل
اعلنت وكاله رويترز ان الجمهوريين في
طريقهم لجوله خامسه من التصويت على رئيس
مجلس النواب
اوكي جوجل
اميره
رامز
المعركه داخل صفوف الجمهوريين هناك انشقاق
في او اختلاف في الراي داخل صفوف
الجمهوريين ويحتاج
حتى اللحظه الى 218 صوتا لكن يمتنع نحو 20
نائب عن اعطاء هذا التصويت ما لم يعطي
تطمنينات
للكثير من التشدد في همم ملفات يا ولد
الكونجرس ومجلس النواب ان يفتحها همم تجاه
الرئيس الديمقراطي
الى ميلا في روسيا خسرت روسيا جنودها بسبب
الهاتف لكنها ماضيه في الحرب ربما للسنوات
مقبله وهو وهي تعد لذلك
فيما اشرف الرئيس الروسي اليوم بنفسه على
انطلاقه سفينه حربيه تحمل صواريخ تسلكون
الفرد صوتيه واعتبر ان الفرقه
قويه وستؤمن لروسيا مصالحها كما ستحميها
من التهديدات
برشام
كرتون
[موسيقى]
بالفعل لا يوجد مثيل له في اي دوله في
العالم انا متاكد من ان هذا السلاح القوي
لروسيا بحمايه نفسها من التهديدات
الخارجيه المحتمله بشكل موثوق وسيساعدنا
في خدمه المصالح الوطنيه لبلدنانا
مع حلولي
الاولى للعمليات العسكريه الروسيه على
الاراضي الاخرانيه الشهر المقبل نشرت
صحيفه نيويورك
الى ساعي الرئيس الروسي فلاديمي بوتين الى
اعداد الروس وجيشه لمعركه طويله في
السنوات المقبله وهذا بعد اعتراف الكلام
السريع بالخسائر للجماعيه التي تسببت بها
اوكرانيا في نهايه الاسبوع الماضي خطوط صن
في مدينه مكيفكا نيويورك تايمز اكدت ان
بلادمر بوتين يعيد التركيز مجددا على
الجبهه الداخليه
ويسعى الى تجنب اي استياء محتمل بشان
العواقب الوخيمه للحرب حيث كان قد اصدر في
وقت سابق قرار
بصدر قرارا بانشائي همم نظام لتدريب
المتخصصين في تطوير وانتاج المسيارات واكد
ايضا ان الغرب لم يحقق اهدافه في تدمير
البلاد مضيفا ان من بدا تلك العقوبات
توقعت تدمير الكامل للصناعه والتمويل
والنقل الروسي لكن لم يحدث هذا بحسب
تعبيره
[موسيقى]
شكلت الهواتف المحموله سبب الرئيسيه لسقوط
عشرات القتله جراء الضربه صاروخيه
الاوكرانيه التي استهدفت الجنود الروسي في
مدينه مكافكا ما يثير سؤالا حول اليه عمل
تلك الهواتف
في المعركه تاتيك الضربه من كل مكان لا
تدري اين مكمان الخطر والخطر قد يكون من
الهواتف الجوال
تصدر الهواتف الجوال اشارات عند استخدامها
من قبل الجنود
تتصل تلك الاشارات بشبكه الخلويه للجهه
المقابله ما يسمح عبر الاقمار الاصطناعيه
بتحديد مكان وموقع الجنود
تلقائيا يتم حفظ معلومات رقم معرفه الجهاز
ورقم التجوال وبالطبع تحركات الجنود
استقبال تلك المعلومات يتم عبر اجهزه
الاستخبارات الغربيه تتوفر لها قدرات
هائله للرصد والمتابعه يتم ارسال
الاحداثيات التي تم التوصل اليها للقوات
الاوكرانيه
لتستفيد من تلك المعلومات في ضرب مواقع
الجنود بالصواريخ او المسيارات
طريقه اخرى باستخدام منظومه لير 3 المكونه
من طائرتين مسيرتين ومركز قياده في شاحنه
عسكريه لتتبع مواقع الهاتف ويمكن لهذه
المنظومه رصد اكثر من الفيهاتف محمول في
مدن يصل الى خمسه كيلومترات و 400 متر مما
يتيح امكانيه العثور على مجموعه كامله من
القوات الروسيه كشف مواقع القوات المنافسه
يتم ايضا من خلال استخدام اجهزه راديو واي
فاي وبلوتوث وعدم تشفير الملفات الحساسه
وتنزيل التطبيقات غير الموثقه
خطا يقع فيه الكثير من الجنود والنتيجه
فقدان ارواحهم بيدي هواتفهم المحموله التي
تطلق عليهم طلقه مميته
العربيه اهلا بك ويعطيك الف عافيه تحت
سقوط هذا الثلج عذرا للانتظار عبد الجواد
يعني اوكرانيا تقول بيت رياض في الطريق
الينا روسيا ردت ان الفرقه تغشكوف جاهزه
للاستخدام ما اهميتها همم بمواجهه مثلا هل
هي بنفس موازين القوى
مساء الخير ااا ريما نعم بالفعل يعني
الحديث عندما يدور عن فرقاك من العيار
الثقيل تلك التي تتحدث عنها موسكو اليوم
فالحوار اصبح طبعا على مدى كبير وطويل
وواسع هذه الفرقه تحمل صواريخ استراتيجيه
من العيار الثقيل وهي سيركون طبعا سيركون
قادر على الوصول والطيران الى مسافات تزيد
عن اكثر من 1000 كيلو متر هذه هي المسافه
تحتاج طبعا لسرعه كبيره عاليه وهذه
الصواريخ تتمتع بهذه الخاصيه وتصل الى
قرابه 10,000 كم في الساعه الواحده التي
ان تتخيلي تقع هذه المسافه لذلك موسكو
تتحدث بانها واثق بانه لا يوجد اي نظام
دفاع جوي او دفاع صاروخي يمكنه اسقاط او
تعطيل او اشتياق هذه الصواريخ طبعا الخروج
بهذه الفرقاء اليوم لا يعتبر القراءه
السياسيه في البلاد
هذا الموضوع صح يعني النظام البيطريات
متطور جدا ليس بجوده الدوم التي تملكها
اسرائيل لكن متطور جدا هل تؤكد او تقول
انه هذه الفرقا همم ممكن ان تتخطى هذا
النظام الدفاعي كالبيتريت مثلا
وهذه الفرقه غير موجهه لاصطياد
بطاريات التي سلمت بها طبعا
واشنطن كيف ذلك هو النظام دفاعي يمكنه
السيطره واحكام القبضه يعني على مناطق
محدده قد تكون صغيره في كيف وكل ما وصل
اليكيه حتى هذه اللحظه باعترافات الجميع
هي بطاريه واحده بطاريه واحده فيها اربع
من الصوت لاطلاق النار كل منصه فيها
ثمانيه صواريخ الحديث يدور عن اثنين
وثلاثين صاروخا فقط يمكنها حمايه مناطق
ملكيه فقط حسب القراءه السياسيه والعسكريه
لهذا الموضوع طبعا نظام باتريوت وحسبه
اعتراف كثيرين لا يمكنه حتى هذه اللحظه
اصطياد بشكل كامل ليست كافه المسيرات يمكن
رؤيتها من هذا النظام الدفاع الجوي ايضا
حسب اعترافات الغرب كما ترى موسكو بان
صاروخا واحدا من كنجال على سبيل المثال
يمكنه ان هذه المنظومه الى دمار لذلك كان
حديث الرئيس ودي مربوطن يعني عشيه راس
السنه بان موسكو ستقوم بتدمير وتعطيل كافه
هذه الانظمه للدفاع الجوي هو واقع حسب
قوله رؤيتهم بهذه القصه
بين روسيا والغرب مكرر بموضوع الهمم همم
الكلام اللي قاله بوتن انه يعد الجيش
الروسي والمجتمع الروسي لحرب طويله همم
هذا بحسب صحيفه نيو تايمز همم هل الشعب
الروسي جاهز لحرب طويله هل يريد هذه الحرب
الطويله
طبعا واقع الحرب ريما كبير جدا على الارض
الروسيه طبعا طبعا لعمليه التعبئه التي
قامت بها موسكو لكن طبعا نلاحظ بان موسكو
كسياسه ودوله هي ذاهبه في عملتها العسكريه
كما تتحدث حتى تحقيق كافه الاهداف لكن
الكثير من يعني من المنظمات لدى الشعب
الروسي العديد من الناس من المواطنين خلال
احاديث
روسيا عن الغرب اليوم مبادئ ايجابيه كما
يرون المبادئ السلبيه هو نظام واحد تسعه
الدوله من اجله هو الوصول لخط الامان خاصه
جميعهم اصبح يدرك تلك المخاوف الامنيه
التي ارسلتها موسكو عبر اعلامها الداخليه
بان الغرب يتقدم نحو الحدود
عسكري او يمكن اكثر الهاتف النقال ليله
راس السنه
لقطتهن لانظمه الرادار وقصفه هل تحت تحقيق
من جانب الروس لماذا فتح هؤلاء الجنود
هواتفهم يعني هل فقط للمعايده براس السنه
مثلا على الخطوط في الاماميه ادت لمجزره
بصفوف الجيش الروسي
الروايه الرسميه تتحدث عن ان فتح الهواتف
المحموله كان لمعايده الذوي طبعا في ليله
راس السنه لكن هي الضربه من العيار الثقيل
تلقاها لكرملين مع بدايه العام الجديد
طبعا ضربه وصلت لكل مواطن روسي الذي تحدث
عن هذا الموضوع تقصير كبير الغالبيه يرون
من قبل وزاره الدفاع من قبل قياده العمليه
العسكريه الخاصه في العراقيه من القائمين
على ذاك المعسكر والتحقيق يجري حتى هذه
اللحظه والجميع مترقب منتظر ريما لما
ستؤول اليه
العربيه وبخبر عاجل ورد الان وزير الدفاع
تركيا يقول يمكن ان نوسع الدوريات
المشتركه مع القوات الروسيه في سوريا هذا
الموضوع سيكون موضوع بحث مع مسؤول سابق في
الاداره الامريكيه مسؤول عن ملف سوريا
وايضا مجلس النواب الامريكيه فشل في
اختيار رئيس له في جوله التصويت الرابعه
واوكرانيا تعتمد العتاد وسلاح الرقمي كيف
ذلك اوكرانيا اليوم قامت بتحميل
قواتها المقاتله الى صيغه رقميه ساعدتها
في التغلب على الاله العسكريه الروسيه
خلال ضماني مقاتلين شبكيين رقميا ااه
ومعلومات استخباراتيه وفقه صحيفه واصل
شبكه الجيش الاوكرانيه التي تضم عشرات
الطائرات بدون طيار والاصله والاسلحه
المتطوره والاتصالات عبر الاقمار الصناعيه
والبرمجيات المخصصه باتت تمنح للجنود
الاوكران مستوى كبير من المهاره وتنسيق
والدقه وتسمح لهم باداره ومتابعه تمركز
الجيوش الروسيه ضخمه
هذه المتابعه ادت الى نجاح اوكرانيا في
توجيه ضربه قويه لروسيا من خلال رصد هواتف
الجنود الروس في مكيفكا
[موسيقى]
وفقه مراقبين نجاح اوكرانيا في تجميع نظام
قياده وتحكم افتراضي الصريح سريع يقدموا
دروسا قيمه للغرب لا سيما حول الحاجه الى
تجربه وتضمين خبراء غير عسكريين حيث قام
المبرمجون الاوكرانيون بتحديث النظام يطلق
عليه الجيش اسم زعلته لمنح القاده
المحليين معلومات استخباراتيه عن ساحه
المعركه في الوقت الفعلي والتي يتم تلقيها
من طائرات بدون طيار ومن مراقبين يعيشون
في الاجزاء التي تحتلها روسيا في اوكرانيا
وبالتالي الجيش الاوكراني سيكون الاكثر
تقدما في المرحله المقبله وذلك من خلال
بناء معدات ووحدات تشويش بطائرات بدون
طيار محليه الصنع ويصنع ايضا وحدات
بطاريات رخيصه عاليه
ابقاء الجنود متصلين بالانترنت اثناء
القتال وهي قفزه جورجيا في 10 اشهر فقط
ويتمثل احد عناصر نجاح اوكرانيا في كيفيه
عمل الوحدات العسكريه المختلفه
وشركات التكنولوجيا الاوكرانيه على
تقنياتها العسكريه الجديده التي تضمن
رقمنا امنه تربط القاده والمقاتلين
والاسلحه والاستخبارات
[موسيقى]
وقع وزير الدفاع البولندي اتفاقا لشراء
شحنه ثانيه من دبابات ابرامز القتاليه
الامريكيه في الوقت الذي تسعى به وارسو
لتعزيز القدرات الدفاعيه وتكثيف تعاونها
العسكري مع واشنطن في ضوئي حرب روسيا في
اوكرانيا وقال مسؤولون انا بولندا اول
خليفه للولايات المتحده في اوروبا تحصل
على دبابات
وتتابعونا في نشره المساء ولكن بعد قليل
اتحاد النقل الجوي ايات ينتقدوا فحوصات
كورونا للمسافرين من الصين
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد بعد قرن من زمان نفس
السيناريو يتكرر في الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه خلافات عميقه تلقي بظلالها على
افتتاح الكونجرس فبعد اربع جولات اقتراح
متتاليه فشل مجلس النواب الامريكي في
انتخاب رئيسه والسبب رفض بعض الجمهوريين
من الجناح اليمين المحافظ وحزب الشاي
ومؤيدين لترامب التصويت لصالح كيف
المكارسي ما يضع مستقبل هذا السياسي على
المحاك اذا لم تنجح ما ساعي كفن مكرسي في
اقناع المعارضين رغم عددا من التنازلات
التي قدمها ورضوه لدعواتهم المطالبه
باجراء تحقيقات عميقه تطالب ديمقراطيين من
بينهم الرئيس بعد سيطره على المجلس فهؤلاء
ضلوا على رايهم بانهم معتدل اكثر مما
ينبغي وقال مات جايتس النائب عن ولايه
فلوريدا لا يؤمن باي شيء وليس لديه
ايدولوجيا
في الاثناء اجتمع كبن مكارث في خلف ابواب
مغلقه مع مجموعه من المحافظين من اليمين
الذين يرفضون منحه اصواتهم ليصبح رئيس
مجلس النواب في وقت يشهد فيه الكونجرس
فوضى كبيره
[موسيقى]
ويحتاج انتخاب رئيس مجلس النواب اغلبيه من
218 صوتا وهي عتبه لم يتمكن من بلوغها اذ
ينقصه 16 صوتا بعد ان قرر نحو 20 نائبا من
مؤيدي ترامب عرقله انتخابه وفي حال فشل
ماكارتي فان العضو الجمهوري في مجلس
النواب الثاني نائب ستيف سكاليس من
الوزاره
يبدو خيارا واضحا وهو محافظ محبوب على
نطاق واسع من قبل زملائه وينظر او ينظر
اليه البعض على انه بطل ويمكن لانتخاب
رئيس لمجلس النواب ان يحتاج لاكثر من جوله
اختراعه فقبل قرن وتحديدا في عام 1923
اختارا النواب رئيسا للمجلس بعد اكثر من
جوله اقتراع وفي عام 1855 لم ينتخب النواب
رئيسا للمجلس الا بعد شهرين
و133 دوره اقتراح اما ترامب فقط كتب على
موقع
بعد ارجاء جلسه مجلس النواب امس كتب يقول
ان هناك الكثير من الاضطرابات غير المبرره
في الحزب الجمهوري محملا متش مكانل بشكل
خاص مسؤوليه الانقسام محذرا من تحويل
النصر الى هزيمه محرجه
[موسيقى]
حسين التوض معنا مراسل العربيه حسين
تقريبا 20 النائب يعارضون وصول مقاسي هل
تغير راي اي حدا من بعد ثلاث جولات اربع
جولات هل ااا غير اي شخص رايه
تحيه لك ريما يبدو ان الرقم 20 سيكون عقده
لمكار في فبالفعل البارحه كان هناك 20 شخص
نائبا عفوا صوت ضده واليوم قبل ذلك ان
هناك 19 في جولتين الاولى ولكن هناك حديث
الان او احاديث داخل وقعه الكونجرس تتحدث
عن سيناريوهات عده اذا فشل مكارثي بالحصول
على 218 صوتا هناك من يقول ان مكارثي يسعى
الى تخفيض العتبه الى اقل من 218 صوتا شرط
ان لا همم يصوت المعارضون له او ان يصوتوا
همم حاضر فقط هناك ايضا حديث عن
سيناريوهات ان يكون همم
هو المرشح الاخر رغم انه مؤيد لمكارتي كما
ايضا هناك حديث عن احتمال قيام عدد من
الجمهوريين المعتدين بالتفاهم مع
الديمقراطيين
لترشيح همم مرشح معتدل يتفق عليها
الجانبان
الديمقراطيين حتى الان همم كما قال عدد من
قادتهم في مجلس النواب يرفضون هذا
الاقتراح وهم لا يستعدونه في المستقبل لكن
الان يقولون الامر همم هو من مسؤوليه
الجمهوريين هناك حديث عديده وهناك افكار
عديده الان تطرح في ظل ال- ال- التصويت
الرابع الفاشل لمكارتي همم حتى دونالد
ترامب الذي دعى مؤيديه في مجلس النواب
للتصويت لصالح مكه لم يسقيها هؤلاء لدعوته
هذا له طبعا مؤشرات اخرى حول همم نفوذ
دونات عليهم ولكن ايجابيا او سلبا هناك
الكثير الان من الاراء الكثير من
السيناريوهات تطرح همم داخل مجلس النواب
كيف سيكون الحال ما الكارتي بنفسه اعلن
انه مستعد للذهاب حتى النهايه تتم اعاده
الانتخابات اكثر من مره حتى يفوز وهو يؤمن
بانه قائد للجمهوريين هو لديه ولكن
الاقليه القليله الموجوده ضده بالوصول
هذا الشاي اولا في بعد تصويت اليوم نعم ام
لا وثانيا هل ممكن لايش اكثر من شخص ان
يترشح يعني مكارثي وشخصيه اخرى ام على
مقرتي ان يتنحى همم
يترشح شخص اخر لرئاسه المجلس
[موسيقى]
طبعا يمكن لاي شخص ان يترشح ولا كتبه هناك
يكون اتفاق داخل الاحزاب مثلا راينا ان
الديمقراطيين متحدون خلف جفرس الان بينما
هناك خلاف داخل الجمهوريين يمكن يترشح
اكثر من عضو جمهوري لرئاسه همم مجلس همم
النواب ولكن طبعا الاغلبيه الان هي داعمه
لمارتي لا يوجد شيء يمنعه يمنع الاخرين من
الترشح ولكن لديه الاغلبيه ليكون هو رئيس
مجلس النواب لكن ما يجري الان ان هذه
الاقليه المتشدده تعرقل وصوله الى هذا
الهدف الذي وضعه لنفسه منذ اكثر من سبع
سنوات عندما احاول المره الاولى عام 2015
في قمه السعاده في قمه السعاده من يرى وجه
نانسي بيلوسي الرئيس السابق البارحه كيف
كانت تبتسم اليوم الديمقراطيون يعني هناك
حاله من ال من من
يقولون بالعاميه التنمير على الجمهوريين
همم
هم هم مرتاحون كما قلت لك هناك طرح لفكره
يصل الى مرشح بين الحزبين طبعا يكون
جمهوري بالنعتدل قال الديمقراطيون القاده
الديمقراطيون حتى الان توافقي يرفضون هذا
الطرح قالوا انه ليس وقته الان الان على
الجمهوريين يعني همم يتحملوا مسؤوليتهم
هناك تحميل الجمهوريه لهذه المسؤوليه
الديمقراطيون مرتاحون الان لا سيما ان
جيفرز كما راينا حصل لليوم الثاني وللمره
الرابعه لمئتين واثني عشر صوتا هناك همم
الاتحاد خالد الاتحاد ديمقراطي بين مناره
داخل الحزب الجمهوري
حسين توت جولات كثيره امامنا معك ومع باقي
المراسلين من واشنطن شكرا جزيلا لك على
هذه المداخله
[موسيقى]
في ايران وبرغم الاعدامات المستمره في حق
المحتاجين شدد المرشد الاعلى لايراني علي
خامنئي على اهميه مشاركه النساء في عمليه
صنع القرار في البلاد مؤكدا انه يجب ايجاد
طريقه لتطبيق تلك المشاركه وانك ونقلت
وكاله الايرانيه الرسميه للانباء عن
فاميلي ان توظيف نساء ايران التي وصفهن
بالحكيمات والخبيرات في مختلف في مستويات
صنع القرار في البلاد موضوع يحظى بالاهميه
وعلى القاده في ايران تحقيق ذلك
يتجنبوا الالمان من اصول ايرانيه سفر الى
ايران خشيه خشيه من تعرضهم للاعتقال حتى
وان لم يكونوا ناشطين سياسيين ياتي هذا في
ما حذرت المخابرات الالمانيه المعارضين من
اصول ايرانيه في المانيا من ان السفر الى
ايران قد يعرضهم لعواقب وخيمه رغبه بهنام
والتفاصيل
فقط لمجموعه من الايرانيين هنا نصبوا خيمه
امام البرلمان التوعيه على الاحتجاجات
والقمعي في ايران تتحدثوا وتشرحوا لمن
يتوقفوا مستفصرا عن الاحتجاجات في وطني
والديها ناهد المولوده في المانيا زارت
ايران للمره الاخيره عام
1987 تقول انها لا تفكر بزياره مجددادا
الى اوراق ايرانيه جديده ايران ترفض نزع
الجنسيه الايرانيه عني بطل بحجه انه قد
احاكم في المانيا
واضطر للجوء الى ايران
[موسيقى]
ناهد واحده من قرابه 200,000 الماني من
اصل ايراني يعيشون هنا وجهه المخابرات
الالمانيه تحذيرا للمعارضين للنظام منهم
قبل ايام من ان السفر الى ايران قد يعرضهم
لعواقب رحيمه وربما تواجدو ناهد هنا كاف
بالنسبه للنظام لتصنيفها معارضه فالناشطنا
هنا يتحدثون عن اشخاص
يراقبونهمس وقبل ذلك صباحا رجل كان يصورنا
ولم يكن نعرف لماذا يصور وما الذي يفعل
وسامعناها يتحدث الفارسيه على الهاتف ولكن
عندما اقترب سالناه قال انه لا يتحدث
الفارسي
مراد وصل الى المانيا قبل الست سنوات
اللاجئا سياسيا كذلك بدات تحركه امام
البرلمان لتشجيع النواب على حظر الحارس
الثوري الايراني
المخاطر التي يواجهها الايرانيون في
المانيا لا تقتصر فقط على المخاوف من
تعرضهم للاعتقال في حال سافروا الى ايران
ولكن هنا ايضا يقولون بانهم يشعرون بانهم
دائما تحت المراقبه من عملاء النظام
الايراني في المانيا
العربيه برلين
[موسيقى]
على وزير
امكانيه توسيعي وتطوير دوريات المشتركه مع
روسيا في شمال السوري
في استمرار المفاوضات الثلاثيه في وزراء
دفعي تركيا وروسيا وسوريا في الفتره
المقبله حول الوضع على الحدود
في الاثناء دعت ولايات المتحده دول العالم
قاطبتان الى عدم تطبيع علاقتها مع نظام
الرئيس السوري بشار الاسد الذي وصفته بدك
تاتاتور الوحشي وذلك في معرض تعليقها على
اللقاء الذي جمع اخيرا في موسكو وزيري
الدفاع السوري والتركي وحضر المتحدث باسمي
وزاره الخارجيه الامريكيه نت برايس الدول
على ان تدرس بعنايه ما وصفه بسجل حقوق
الانسان المروع لنظام الاسد على مدى سنوات
الاثنين 10 الماضيه والاربعاء الماضي عقد
في موسكو اجتماع ضمه وزراء دفاع روسي
وتركي والسوري تناول التقارب مع نظامي
بشار الاسد
سكايب
المبعوث الامريكي السابق الى سوريا اهلا
بك
امريكا تقول لا تطبع مع بشار الاسد ولكن
تركيا دوله مهمه لاعبه اساسيه في الصراع
داخل سوريا لماذا يسمح لتركيا ان
تفتح علاقات مع دمشق والان ورد خبر عاجل
من وزير الدفاع التركي يبحث دوريات مشتركه
مع روسيا مثلا بالشمال السوري
ذا فويس تنجيد المعلم
بشار الاسد لا يمكن ان ينجح سبق وان فشل
ذلك من خلال هؤلاء الذين حاولوا امثله على
ذلك
المتحده والاردن ولكن
الامارات
تحاولوا ان تحقق النجاح في ذلك بانه بغض
النظر اما في التواصل مع بشار الاسد
ستعامل معه هو يغشش الجميع وفي الحقيقه هو
يعاقب كل من يحاول يتعامل معه عن طريق كيف
يتواصل مع بشار الاسد
كبار الشرق الاوسط فما تفعله تركيا في
الحقيقه
مسدوده وستفشل
التقيت انا وانت قبل كونا قبل ثلاث سنوات
وكانت بدات الولايات المتحده بفرج عقوبات
وكنت انت بموقع مسؤول داخل الاداره
الامريكيه قلت لي انه هذه العقوبات ستنجح
وان بشار الاسد سيفشل بشار الاسد باقن
ويتمدد وموجود لمده 12 سنه وسوريا يعني
خسر العالم سوريا لكن بشار الاسد
اين سيفشل كيف هو الفشل لا زال موجوده
الى اقتصادي بشار الاسد
كامل
حتى اليوم في مجتمعات اعتقد قبل عامين كنا
لن نقول بانها كانت مواليه جدا لنظام
الاسد حتى هي على
الوقوف والاحتياج ضده
لا يوجد اي مستقبل على المتوسط اول بعيد
لبشار الاسد
فقط
عن بشار الاسد
تدخل وتخذ موقفا اشد
وخاصه فيما يخص المساله الضغوط من الخارج
على الاسد
لو ارادت الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
الاطاحه ببشار الاسد لكانت اطاحت به من
سنوات لماذا بقي لماذا ابقت عليه الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه
واشنطن 99% منهم يرغابون برحيل الاسد
وتجربه ان هي النظام صدام حسين
لقد تعلمنا ذلك
كثير
التحول او الانتقال السياسي في الولايات
المتحده ترغب برحيل الاسد
استخدام
لتحقيق ذلك
على طول الحديث لكن ذهبنا الوقت
كان معي من واشنطن المبعوضه الامريكي
السابق الى سوريا
[موسيقى]
شددت وزيره الخارجيه الالمانيه
على ضروره تنسيق المشترك مع منظمه الصحه
العالميه بشان مواجهه اوروبا موجاتي
كورونا القادمه من الصين
هدفنا ايجاد حل مشترك ويجب ان نتعامل مع
هذه الموجه القادمه من الصين بجديه فارغه
ولن نتحدث عن تعاون الاوروبي فقط بلد
تعاون مع منظمه الصحه العالميه ايضا من
اجل الشفافيه الكامله حول الوضع في الصين
اشترطت فرنسا تقديم نتيجه اختبار تثبت
الخلوه من الاصابه بكبد نايلسين على
القادمين من الصين وقال المتحدث باسم
الحكومه الفرنسيه اوليفيا بيرون ان ذلك
الاجراء ضروري لحمايه المواطنين من
الاصابه بالفايروس
اوروبا لا توجد دوله تريد ان
ترددها ليس بعد كل الجهود والتضحيه التي
بذلت على مدى سنوات الثلاث الماضيه
اعتبارا من الخامس
القيود المفروض على السفر ضد المسافرين من
الصين بحجه ان مثل هذه التدابير قد ثبت
انها غير فعاله في منع انتشار نعم المدير
العام للاتحاد الدولي للنقل الجوي اياتا
عبر عن اسافه جراءه عوده قيود كورونا في
بعض المطارات مجددا رغم ثبوت فشل تلك
القيود الى ثلاث سنوات ماضيه على حد
تعبيرها
مستمره نشره المساء وفي سياقها
بعد رواسه منذ القرن التاسع عشر المانيا
تودع خدمه الثلج رعب
[موسيقى]
بتابعوا نشات المساء من واشنطن مباشره
جوله خامسه لانتخاب رئيس المجلس النواب
الامريكي
وهذه مشاهد مباشره
[موسيقى]
هو الحب رئيسا
[تصفيق]
النواب
ما الذي يدفعني كمحافظ
[موسيقى]
ومشارك سابق في الجيش لماذا ارشح كيف
المكاتي ليصبح الرئيس القادم لهذا المجلس
لماذا
او اي محافظه اخر مثل
رئيس المجلس
شايف في طبيعتنا كبشر يدفعنا
لتقليل من الشاميه الاخرين عندما ننخرط في
النزاعات
وهذا يجعل من السهل ان
لن نخرط في
السجلاته وكذلك يصعب العمر على فهم بعضنا
البعض
بيننا
اليوم
واناشد الجميع
وكل زملائي الجمهوريين
يجب ان تنتصر العقول الهادئه
ولنتتحد كجمهوريا للانتخابات الرئيس
القادم للمجلس
بخلافه الديمقراطيه فكل الجمهوريه على اقل
ايدوب او يقدم حكومات
وعودا في حمله انتخابيه
في جوله خامسه لمجلس النواب الامريكي
لاختيار الرئيس
في صفوف في منافسهم
الى العراق تشهدوا معظم المدن العراقيه
حالته طول امطار غزيره منذ صباح اليوم
غريقه على اثرها عدد من الاحياء في
العاصمه ومدن كربلاء والنجف من جانبها
اعلنت محافظه بغداد استنفار الجهود الخاصه
بتصريف واستيعاب كميات مياه الامطار كما
منحت وزاره التربيه في بغداد
مديرياتها في بقيه المحافظات حريه تقدير
الموقف بتعطيل المدارس من عدمه
[موسيقى]
عقد في اسطنبول اجتماعيه تشاوري يدعو الى
سرعه اجراء الانتخابات تربيه ثاني رغبه
الشارع الليبيه الذي ينادي بانتخابات دون
اقصاء واكيد هناء للجميع شركاء في الوطن
كما دعا المجتمعون الامم المتحده والبعث
الامميه الى احترام رغبه الليبيين في
تقرير مصيرهم
هذا الاجتماع
وتوحيد المؤسسات الدوله
وفي الصومال اعلنت الشرطه الصوماليه
ارتفاع عدد القتلى جرائم في جرائم في وسط
البلاد الى 35
وذكر مسؤولون اميون ان حركه الشباب وراء
الهجومين الذين استهدفان منطقه سكنيه في
بلده محاسبه اقليم هيران وسط الصومال
بسيارتين محملتين بل متفجرات واشار
المسؤولون ايضا
جميعهم من المدنيين
[موسيقى]
تويتر يلغي الحظر الذي فرضه على الاعلانات
السياسيه منذ عام 2019 ضمن احدث
استراتيجيه يسعى من خلالها الى الماس
لزياده الايرادات بعد شرائه العصفور
الازرق
من عرض الاعلانات التي تدعم المرشحين او
تروش لاجراءات الاقتراع او تطلب التبرعات
وفقا التي اكدت ان شركه تويتر مقبله على
احدث تغيير في سياستها في مجال الاعلانات
التي سترفع مستوى الوعي فيما يتعلق
بالمشاركه المدنيه والنمو الاقتصاديه
والاشراف البيئي وحتى الاجتماعى وايضا
توسيعه دعايه سياسيه في المرحله المقبله
بعد ان كان تحضر جميع اشكال الدعايه
السياسيه عام 2019 ردا على تصاعد القلق
بشان المعلومات التي تنتشر على وسائل
تواصل الاجتماعي
اعلان وصف بالمهم وفقه مراقبين منذ ان
اكمل ماسك استحواذ هو على شركه في اكتوبر
الماضي بقيمه 44 مليار دولار وهنا يجب
الاشاره الى ان معظم عائدات تويتر تاتي من
الاعلانات ففي عام 2021 كان ما يقرب من
5.1 مليار دولار من الارباح عن طريق
الاعلانات لكن بعدها قامت بعض الشركات
بتعليق الانفاق الاعلاني على المنصه بعد
الاستحواذ والصحاله من عدم اليقين بشان
كيفيه التخطيط السيد معسكر لاداره الشركه
وبالفعل منذ ديسمبر انخفض انفاق 100 جهه
على الاعلانات على تويتر وفقا لتحليل
البيانات من شركه الابحاث بسماكس وفقه
مراقبين فقرات تويتر اليوم هو فوز واضح
لحوريات التعبير ولكن يبقى ان نرى مدى
تاثيره على ارباح الشركه خصوصا وان تويتر
المساج الى اثبات فكره ان ساحه المدينه
الرقميه هي قناه فعاله لاقناع الناخبين
وصانع السياسات
[موسيقى]
ينضم الينا من عمان رائد سمور الخبير في
امن المعلومات وناشر موقع ارابيوس التقني
اهلا بك سيد رائد اييي ما خطوره ان يفسح
المجال مجال تويتر امام المعلنين خاصه من
الاطراف السياسيه وكيف ممكن لتويتر ان
يحدد ااه مثلا اذا كان طرف سياسي موالا
لايران او ل اا منظمه صنفها الجماعات
الدوليه بالارهابيه همم الخطوط السياسيه
فضفاض بعض الشيء
مساء الخير نعم هي الامور من الصعب
التمييز ما بين
الخطاب السياسي والاعلان السياسي من هذا
المنطلق انا اعتقد انه تويتر يحاول او سيد
الى ماسك يحاول من خلال هذه الخطوه خلط
اوراق اللعبه السياسيه داخل الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه خاصه انه في ال 2019
قبل ما يكون هو مستحود على المنصه وقبل
الانتخابات الامريكيه السابقه الرئاسيه
السابقه في ال 2019 كان في هناك صراع ما
بين الحزب الجمهوري والديمقراطي على تويتر
وموضوع حجب الاعلانات كان لصالح الحزب
الديمقراطي وبالتالي همم كان دونالد ترامب
همم
عنيد جدا في مخاصمته لتويتر وكان يعني
نوعا ما تحميل من مسؤوليه خسارته
بالانتخابات اللي مثل هذا القرار الان في
احنا عندنا بال23 السنه القادمه من عندنا
2024 بالتالي في كمان انتخابات وانا اعتقد
انه هذه المرحله الان مرحله تحضير
للانتخابات الرئاسيه في 2024 ولعل الاعلان
الرسمي الذي قام به ايلون ماسك بانحيازه
المباشر في السياسه تحديدا وانعيازه الى
جانب الحزب الجمهوري وبالتالي انا اعتقد
انه هذه عمليه خلط للاوراق داخل همم
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه تحديث
الانتخابات في الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
بتجير الاصوات وايضا في الغرب اوروبا
ببريطانيا كان في اتهامات انه بيروت لان
تستعمل من الصوت وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي
ناهيك الان هناك حرب مع روسيا يعني غير
مباشره بين غير وروسيا سؤالي همم
هل هل الموضوع الاعلان السياسي فقط في
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه ام سيكون
مفتوح عالميا هل بامكان اي فريق سياسي ان
يشتري الاعلان على تويتر
نعم مادام فتح الباب سوف يكون بامكان اي
فريق سياسي ان يقوم بالاعلان السياسي عبر
تويتر لكن هل درجه التقييد في نشر هذا
المحتوى قد تختلف من مدينه الى مدينه او
من بلد الى بلد او طبيعه ونوع هذا المحتوى
ايضا قد يختلف تقييده واطلاقه من خلال هذه
المنصه
حتى الاعلان السياسي هل نعرف مباشره
يؤثر بالرئي السياسي يعني اعرف انه تويتر
بيتبعه اصحاب الاخبار اللي بهمم الاخبار
والسياسه لكن هل فعلا انه اذا اشتريت
اعلان على تويتر بتجيب اصوات اا في الشارع
يعني من المفهوم
الطبقه السياسيه او من يعمل بالسياسه او
المهتمين بالسياسه دخلوا الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه هم من متابعين منصه تويتر
ومناصه طبعا تروث الخاصه بالسيد دونالد
ترامب ففعمليا نعم نعم تستطيع ان تؤثر كما
اثرت فضيحه كامبردج انا ليتيكا زي ما
حضرتك تحدثت بالانتخابات الامريكيه ابان
كلينتون ترامب نعم تستطيع اي منصه في
التواصل الاجتماعي لديها
عشرات الملايين ان لم يقل ان لم يكن مئات
الملايين من المستخدمين على مثل هذه
المنصات وهذا التاثير تاثير مباشر يستطيع
ان يصل المحتوى على مستوى
الفردعه
تفضل الاعلان بوسائل تواصل الاجتماعي مش
معروف بعد اذا عم بيجيب فلوس هل بعود
الخسائر انه الماسك بفتح المجال الامام
السياسه
والله عودنا عودنا لهن ماسك هو ثعلب
بالحال الرقميه ودائما يبحث عن حلول والان
هو يعيش في مازق اللي هو تجميد الاعلانات
90% من وارداته تاتي من خلال الاعلانات
والان الجزء الاكبر من المعلنين احجموا عن
هذا الاعلان بشكل كامل عبر هذه المنصه
فشلت العلامه الزرقاء ومشروع العلامه
الزرقاء وبالتالي هو الصداره هذه
الاستداره نحو الاعلان السياسي وفتح الباب
امام الاعلان السياسي من اجل تعويض
الخسائر التقنيه
[موسيقى]
قدما رئيس الوزراء البريطاني ريشي سوناك
خمسه وعود للناخبين لبناء مستقبل افضل
للشعب كما يقول وتحقيق راحه البال وشمل
تعهداته
تعهداته تخفيض التضخم وتنميه الاقتصاد
وتقليس قوائم انتظار في المستشفيات وتخفيف
الديون والسيطره على الهجره غير النظاميه
مصطفى زار والتفاصيل
عن اولويات حكومته في مواجهه تحديات البلد
لدينا خمسه وعود تخفيض التضخم الى النصف
تنميه الاقتصاد وخفض الديون وقوائم
الانتظار في الصحه ووقف القوارب تلك هي
اولويات الشعب انها اولويه حكومتكم
خطاب سناك ياتي في وقت يعاني فيه ملايين
البريطانيين من غلاء المعيشه وترد الخدمات
العامه ولاسيما في القطاع الصحي في بلادي
لزياده عدد الاسره بمقدار سبعه الاف سرير
في المستشفيات ومن يتلقون الرعايه في
المنزل
شرطه وتدريس التلاميذ الرياضيات حتى سن
الثامنه عشر وختم هناك خطابه بالتاكيد على
ان اولويات المواطنين هي اولويات حكومته
ويؤكد وعزمه على اعاده الثقه في السياسه
هناك يدعو الناخبين لبناء احكامهم على
فتره
انطلاقا من تعهداته وقدرته على الوفاء بها
بالرغم من التحديات التي تواجهه قبل عامين
من الانتخابات العامه
مصطفى زاروه العربيه لندن
[موسيقى]
اما الاعلام الدوليه بشكل غير مسبوق بحفل
تقديم النجم البرتغالي كريستيانو رونالدو
لاعبا جديدا لنادي النصر السعودي على
ارضيه ملعب مرسول مبارك بالعاصمه السعوديه
رياض في ما يلي نستعرض ابرز عناوين الصحف
والمواقع العالميه التي تحدثت عن الموضوع
[موسيقى]
الغاز شركه البريد الالمانيه
باسم الشركه بان هذه الخطوه ترجعوا الى ان
الخدمه لم يعد يجري استخدامها في الفتره
الاخيره مشيرا الى اندوتش بوس تبعت في ذلك
ما فعلته العديد من شركات البريد على
مستوى العالم ويرجع اختراع التلجراف الى
القرن التاسع عشر واستمر استخدامه حتى وقت
طويل من القرن العشرين كواحد من اسرع
الوسائل لنقل معلومات المهمه
ختام ونشره المساء الى العنويه
قتل يعد الروس لحرب او يعد رؤوس لحرب
طويله جدا ويشرف على انطلاق فرقات بصواريخ
عابره
في المانيا ايرانيون يخشون على حياتهم من
مخابرات بلادهم ويطالبون بحظر حرس الثوري
ين بالفوضى والترامب يدعو الى عدم تحويل
النصر لهزيمه محرجه
لتعويض يا خسائر بعد تعليق عده شركات
اعلانات على المنصه تويتر يسمح للسياسيين
باستخدام المنصه للترويج
نشاط المساء انتهت لكن زميل طاهر موجود
وفي جوله 360 مع العربيه